there was actually a day when magnus was
talking like hell i actually saw this is
his last game i mean it's a tournament
for sure and maybe not only in the
tournament like i was really scared
and we had the as a pcr uh the same day
like after the games i was pretty sure
okay then we'll continue without him but
somehow he managed to swipe yeah he's
working
and then now and now it feels like he
he looks fresh and uh
he has no issues and so on but there was
a day when he i mean it seems that he
felt shaky i don't know maybe my my
impression was wrong but
who knows
this is like always actually this is why
i don't like playing uh i mean in this
lockdown yeah you you come to the round
and then we start this like mafia card
game yeah you're trying to figure out
who's like who feels bad who you should
avoid i mean
like you want to keep distance from
everybody but you cannot so you should
allow some people to be close and some
people should be
um sort of isolated from you you think
and so on yeah